Hello Bruce is Soejima, who is in charge of character design for 5 the royal
.
Today
I would like to talk a little
about whether the new character Kasumi was born on Saturday.
It was first told that there was such an existence in the presence of people.
Well
, I started out from the place where information such as age and what kind of position the character was with respect to the main character
came in.
a I  I remember a little bit, but I think that age was decided. I think that it is a
junior
and
this is that secret, but I think that you can understand it if you play it loosely,
but what kind of story is it and the market  The important thing was that
there was a setting that you would be a person tomorrow at that time. I wrote that based on the information up to that point.
When designing the haze, there were twists and turns at the very beginning of
the new gymnastics.  I want to think about when a new character appears in a wide
area. There is always something that can be a starting point when designing that design
.  As I saw on the site,
it's been a long time since I could beat the Internet, but
[Music]
When I designed the beginning,
I thought I should go with this.
It was a picture of how to tie it
. When I saw this, I thought it was cute, so I could
n't see the face, but that kind
of imagination with a hazy face expanded.  There is something other than the big pen
haze, isn't
it? It
's a picture of an actual person rather than that cartoon character. Even if you're not a famous person, it's good at
all.
Only the photo is a feeling that I remember well with bamboo and grilling,
isn't it? It's
like a girl's cartoon,
it has an atmosphere and it feels girly.I want to put such a character in
the middle of that pi bar on p5.  Characters
that are not in the unbranded ones of good beans
I think it's a ter, so what do
you call it from there? I remember that the design went on and on in a design sense, apart from the profile
.  However,
there are similar pictures
,
and the feeling of this
bangs I started designing from the point that it feels good to be on the top, but since I
have to write the
face next time, the most important thing on the face is the bangs and eyes  By the way, I think it's
a girly young child who should have
bangs, so I write external
bangs like this
, but Kasumi is a bright child, so my
eyebrows are a little cheerful.
On the other hand, Kaiji-kun's eyebrows are like this. When you
come to a high position, if you can't see the outside, you'll look like a little expressionless child
.
Opened that cheerful character
here here, but it's just pouring it, isn't it?
It's
an atmosphere that tends to look down, so that putt like a haze To make
that
rice open and energetic, write it as
if the top and bottom are facing outward from the center as much as possible
.  The first impression I write is the naming part.
Well, especially
I write with an emphasis on the bangs and the atmosphere of that noodle plum, but it's
not just Persona 5 Campaign
The main character of 4  In that case, the character has a sharp eyebrow that seems to remove the gong from the bangs, and
when it
's the best
textured face, player What kind of impression does it give to the person who sees the character first
?  This is most determined by the relationship between the bangs and the woman, so focus on this area
, whether you can see the eyebrows, how much you can see,
whether the bangs are easy to flow in the wind, and the impression of this area.
The character may start writing with the most importance. The
most different thing is
under that eyebrow. The hair is the most different. That Kasmin's design is ahead.
It was decided that it was decided to do club activities, but
what kind of club activities were not decided at first
,
so a but that scenario writer first proposed a ace.  He was a good player, wasn't
he? He was a day player. At first, noon Noon
was the one who made it really short because he didn't have a character with very short hair
.
I felt
like how about a character with such a kanji
, but
it seems like I stopped talking about something that seems a bit unpleasant
.
What a cloak or coat, it's the
same as the good throwing hero.
I still don't understand the story that it
is stationary when I see that picture, but what is it when a new
person with the same rank as the other main character
comes out
?  In order to get interested in the fact that the main characters are the customers who approach,
I dare to wear the same clothes as the main characters
, rather than setting it up to have a pizza.  It
feels like I'm wearing it to get interested, so I guess it's like telling the mask on a white paper and making it a
black day,
isn't it? I didn't intend to write the hero of the Kotobuki version that day 3  In p, a female hero
came out, but unlike that, it's not the hero, it's just another character, but with
some of those points, what if
another hero's
answer comes out
?  I say that it's an approach, but I say that I put my own personality
into it, but if
anyone thinks of that part of Sandrion, the item is that
glass shoe, so if it's just a Mac, it's quite a year of growth on that screen.  That's why trying to make
all the
dresses live up to this line with magical power like this
is the very first
opportunity to start writing. That kind of element I want to write is a very dream story.
There are various visuals, but yes  It feels like I want to put in a lot of
things like that, but the decorations on the top of the cloak for the last five years are
like putting in the image that the pumpkin's clock has a high rate.  I want to
put this in to scrape it. The biggest part is high school, isn't it? If you
look closely here, there are
numbers written on it, but when it comes to this clock, it's on
the right side.  Look at it repeatedly. It's not a character, it's this 66, but it's
a clock here. Well, this is
still such a fairy tale, but being a princess is the power to melt someday
.  Therefore, it is not direct to say that the true self that is a temporary figure now will appear after this,
but the point that is expressed in connection with the story is
the price of the watch here.  Maybe
I write a directly, but basically
designing with is my job, and I design and write by myself,
but that's the case at that time, but that character  But I do
n't know that the character will continue to exist even if I don't write it because the character is being sought after by various people, but
I'm still 10 or 20 years from now.  Even if you don't write it, it's a dream that various people write it and the character
stays alive. It's not universal as a design to be loved for a long
time, but that
basic part is done properly.  It
feels like a proof that I'm getting it, so it's not that long since I've been working
now, but in the future,
the characters we've created will
be long again.  I think it's a dream to keep making it with the hands of various people.